Battlefield games are known for massive
multiplayer sessions but dice is putting
some real love into battle field one
single player campaign I'm Tony and this
is your war-torn gamespot news update we
already knew the game would feature
multiple protagonists but now we've seen
the faces of these heroes battlefield
one is said to have four lead characters
a fighter pilot and armor crewman a
rebel fighter and a message runner the
trailer also shows off the game's wide
variety of action from open fields too
tight corridors to dog fights in the sky
lead designer Danny Berlin has stated
that the campaign will quote more
accurately reflect battlefields open
sand boxes from the looks of the trailer
it seems to live up to that description
battlefield one is coming to ps4 xbox
one and pc on october 21st pre-ordering
the early and lister edition or joining
EA access gets you into the multiplayer
in solo action even earlier we'll have
plenty more gameplay and coverage as we
get closer to launch and for all the
biggest battlefield news you're already
in the right place